[Musique]
cette exposition histoire de sport
national géographique a été construite
et développée avec le Sénat on s'est dit
que c'était une superbe opportunité en
fait de pouvoir mettre en avant les
valeurs du sport à travers ces 80
photographies à que moi du lancement des
jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
[Musique]
2024 national géographique a pu trouver
des photographies de sport qui ont été
prises en amont ou pendant des
photorportages qui étaient dédiés à des
sujets complètement différents et les
photographes ont choisi d'immortaliser
des moments de joie des moments de
partage des moments de vie parfois quand
la vie revenait à après des drames après
des pandémies après des drames
géopolitiques et c'est ça qui ressort de
cette exposition c'est la joie et la vie
qui
reprend vous avez une exposition qui
réunit à travers les valeurs de
l'olympisme les valeurs aussi que nous
devons porter dans notre pays
c'est-à-dire cette solidarité le lien
entre les femmes et les hommes mais
aussi ces valeurs de respect et de
dépassement de soi
on a cette conviction depuis 135 ans
depuis notre fondation que on ne protège
bien que ce qu'on aime et pour pouvoir
aimer quelque chose il faut le connaître
et c'est pour ça qu'on a pensé cette
exposition dans toute sa diversité dans
tout ce que le sport avait de beau sur
tous les continents de 1880 jusqu'à
2021 on partle de ce qui relie les gens
relie les hommes
au-delà de du lieu d'habitation de leur
classe sociale on parle des valeurs
communes qui nous rassemble mais c'est
aussi les histoires qu'ell raconte qui
nous ont intéressé au moment encore une
fois où Paris se prépare à accueillir
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
[Musique]